all right what's up buddy hey lyrics
how's it going good what's crackalackin
hey just always appreciate your stuff
and I got some questions for you uh yeah
Europe was cool I had an idea that you
would uh like it and make and may think
about putting another thing down you
were talking about your boat stuff um so
that's cool looking forward to that um
fresh and fit
their business model they uh they're
going to rumble basically it seems and
you know Myron's tripping uh what any
thoughts on
because if I was I was talking about a
friend recently trying to do like
internet internet stuff internet uh
anything and uh that happens a day after
so it's kind of fun the the YouTube
Partner program lets you monetize your
channel and they haven't removed them
from YouTube they've just demonetized
the channel which means they won't they
can't get super chats and they can't uh
run ads on their videos they can't get
super thanks they can't participate in
um there's a sponsorship program I can't
remember what it's called they can't
sell t-shirts or any of the stuff that's
sort of like all incorporated into it so
um I I haven't talked to Myron in a long
time uh so I don't know what his
revenues would look like I mean he was
he was a mentor of mine years ago before
he even started the fresher Fit channel
but um I mean I would estimate they were
probably doing 75 000 to 100 000 in uh
super chats monthly and about 100 to 150
000 in ad Revenue so that's a lot of
money I mean you know they've probably
lost about a quarter million dollars in
Revenue monthly
um so that means that they're probably
gonna have to make some changes about
how they run the channel and find other
ways to monetize they'll probably have
to crowdfund yeah um you know from Their
audience
um I did like I never really understood
the whole
like like 7500 I think it was two or
three years ago there's a website
somebody showed me that organized
um the most super chatted channels on
the internet and I think like the
Freshman fit podcast was like number one
in North America oh wow okay and I think
they said at that time it was like 75 to
85 000 a month in super chats I never
understood the amount of money people
throw yeah and super Chats on that show
um it really just seems to be like to
like [__] on like the guests like you
know like look at this 304 and whatever
you know same thing with whatever
podcasts do it's yeah just to disparage
them I don't know so
um I don't know so I mean Byron I was
talking some friends about this other
day Myron actually reached out to me a
couple weeks ago or about a week ago and
he asked me to come on a show so yeah I
don't know I gotta I gotta figure that
out but
hopefully it works out for them I'm sure
he'll figure it out he's not stupid yeah
this is the first Domino though I just
kind of worry about uh the viability of
not only your stuff but anyone else that
you know myself or anyone else that was
looking and finding a lot of value from
this man talk stuff and being able to do
it in the future
um but YouTube probably isn't going to
be the thing forever either hopefully
there's something else yeah I hopefully
X or Twitter or whatever we're gonna end
up on this thing in the future will be
like the real deal I mean if anybody's
got the the balls the gumption the
foresight to
fix a free speech platform especially a
video platform hopefully hopefully they
can integrate it in there too
um I hope it's Elon musk's
um and
maybe it happens like we'll see
um you had a couple other things too
that you want to yeah somebody here said
that uh freshman fit was a little too
Jerry Springer that's that's probably
the best way to sort of like
sum it up as it's I'm American whatever
people can do whatever they want in my
opinion and it's kind of weird that
they're you know stepping in on one
person and it just makes me think that
they're going to keep going
um it's not going to stop there
essentially that was just that's I mean
I'm surprised they were monetized as
long as they were yeah they were doing
with the yelling and agreement and the
girls that would come in with the guns
and all that sort of stuff like there's
some weird [__] that went down so yeah
you had a good point about that list
that you mentioned though that's
probably how they deduce two to go after
because if they're the the top kind of
of that kind of content as well that's
good and easy and by the way you know
keep in mind like YouTube loses I think
it's 45 of that Revenue oh wow you see
what I'm saying like it's like it's
almost half that YouTube just said you
know what [__] it we don't need this
money anymore we're just gonna cut them
off and we don't need it so from a
business perspective I mean that's
that's where they are interesting all
right well uh soft white underbelly did
you see the episode or you're maybe
familiar with the the channel uh they
had a divorce lawyer I know you've had
yeah I saw that actually the other day
and I didn't realize that that's a
slightly older video somebody shared it
my community uh like three or four
months ago yeah
I got the clips from the manosphere
highlights daily Channel here's some
decent stuff I think it's at least funny
um yeah but I watched the whole thing
last night and it was that the Romanian
guy no it's uh he's in he's in New York
I believe because he's divorced James
Sexton and uh he had a lot of good
points no no I'm talking about the
manager highlight Channel
I haven't looked into it too much shaves
his head or is that another Channel I
don't think I've ever seen a picture of
him but no okay so I haven't seen that
but like I haven't seen the clips but I
watched the whole video and I thought it
was interesting because because a lot of
it's sort of solidified and echoed what
I wrote in my book in the chapters when
it came to you know love and marriage
and divorce and all that sort of stuff
yeah um he sounded a lot like my divorce
lawyer to be honest with you yeah in
fact I think my divorce lawyers got
better stories but he doesn't want to
talk about them publicly and that's a
missed opportunity I mean the other
thing about like the soul mates and yeah
that was really interesting and then he
said something about the judge agreeing
with him when he mentioned that it was
it was pitiful that his client had to go
get a 50 you know hand sessions hand
jobs yeah yeah yeah and uh and I was
like wow the judge actually agreed with
that no I've never been uh married
divorced whatever got any of that kind
of stuff but I was just smart lawyers
that know how to you know like run the
system right okay yeah yeah yeah that
was that was really interesting and he
you know he was a character so it just
kind of gives me ideas to uh that by the
way that's the kind of guy that you want
to be your divorce lawyer if you have to
untie the knot like a guy like that is
the the atypical sort of alpha male
player that's been in the game that
knows how to run run you through the
gauntlet without without destroying your
life too badly yeah yeah I was very uh
it was he was entertaining at least so
yeah and
um I got another guy waiting man did you
have anything else or can I bounce it
that's it for now yeah brother thanks
man appreciate it I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out